when you bring me out can you introduce
me as Joker now you've said in the past
that you would do a comic-book movie if
the right role came up why was this the
right role for you I think it was
complex in a way that the other movies
that I kind of thirty with one and so I
thought that it was gonna be challenging
for me as an actor I thought it's gonna
be challenging for the audience and
that's exciting to me you know I may
always look for characters that aren't
easy to define and they're surprising in
many ways and so that's what this was I
mean I I kind of you here Joker and I
think anybody has their kind of idea of
what they think that film will be I
think Todd and Scott silverscript really
when one ways that I couldn't couldn't
have expected personally I'm just super
interesting about it I felt that way
watching it yesterday I was like I
almost forgot we were in Gotham some of
the times and there was like a couple of
things in there that I was like oh yeah
this isn't the DC Universe but I it kind
of escapes your mind because you're
really just focused on this character I
think they really blended took their own
unique version of this world while still
maintaining some of the kind of Gotham
Batman Joker mythos and I want to talk
about the Joker's laughs because that's
probably his most iconic trade
especially in the comics and there's so
many different versions of Joker was
that something that you had to audition
with was that one of the first things
you tackled and how did you come up with
that laughs wait a minute how do you
know this how do I know what what do you
what do you mean did I have to audition
for it that's the real story how do you
know about that I mean I do my research
and I like I figured you might have
auditioned with a very impressive thank
you yeah it's funny because I had the
part but I
I felt like I needed to audition the
laughs because I I didn't know if I had
it or not so I asked ought to come over
to my house and to you know
audition the laughs and he said that
wasn't necessary and I said it was it
was very important that I was able to do
it in front of him whenever I needed to
so it's I don't know how you know about
that that that story have never told him
before but he's like you got the part
and you're like no I insist
yeah there's really it was it was
important that I was able to do it it
was a it was a it was a struggle and I
thought at some point it would become
easier but I don't think it did it
became more difficult actually to do
while you were filming you mean yeah I
don't know you don't know there were
there were some scenes where I guess for
whatever reason it came out and it felt
right and other scenes that it was it
was a struggle and sometimes one tape
would work and another wouldn't it just
was I think something that was alive in
a way and I don't know what affected
that yeah well I want to say it's kind
of a cliche question when when people
are like the physical transformation but
it was so you know a parent watching
this movie was that something that was
your decision to you know lose a ton of
weight or was that a you and Todd
collaboration the first thing that that
I started was the effects and the side
effects of medication and one thing that
everybody was talking about all these
bores was about how their medication it
affected their weight and some people
talked about losing a lot of ways people
talk about gaining weight
and I said let's go with the weight gain
that will be easier for me as an actor
in tests of none and how with the weight
loss and so it it was something that
I've done before and I was I swore when
I did before that never do it again but
it seemed like it was really important
for for the character and I think it
they ended up affecting me in ways that
that I hadn't anticipated and certainly
it affects your emotional mental state
but really I think the thing that but I
didn't expect at all
was how I felt like I could move my body
once I'd lost all that that weight I
don't like this this unique control over
my body and how I moved for whatever
reason I don't know why doesn't really
make sense right
but somehow it kind of gave me a new
unexpected feeling and that became
really important for the character well
that kind of goes into my next thing is
the dancing that was like a big part of
the character I think Todd said it was
important that Joker had music in him
can you talk about coming up with that
specific dance cuz it was kind of it was
very choreographed look specific as well
he kind of had that he had the same
movements he did quite a few times it
was like the I don't know how to call it
[Music]
that particular movement that you just
described was actually from a scene in a
previous draft that then was removed you
describe that movement I thought I was
worthy follows really funny and so that
I think that just kind of carried over
Joker has a certain kind of arrogance
and this need to be kind of revered and
adored and he sees himself as as a as a
king in some ways and I I worked this
choreographer named Marco Michael Arnold
Julian and while we did work on some
specific steps for like that scene
on the stairs we also just sure watching
a lot of videos of dance and there's one
in particular ray Bolger who did this
dance and the song called the old soft
shoe and there is he has this this kind
of arrogant I am in this dance and I saw
that and I'm like immediately knew that
that was joking I think that had kind of
the most profound influence but a lot of
it wasn't choreographed and we've just
found him in the moment
mm-hmm I loved watching it was like once
he kind of goes into full Draper has
that makeup on there's like a different
confidence in the dance I thought I was
- watch um now Todd had said that there
was this was not intended to have
sequels there's no intention of having
one at the moment but it feels like
there is room for you to play that
character again do you feel like you're
one and done or do you feel like you
would would want to play Joker again
I like this answer actually very it's
cryptic he's smiling we don't know well
I gotta let you go thank you so much
[Music]
[Applause]